hallo liebe zuschauer und herzlich
willkommen zurück zu carré antwortet ja
heute beantworte ich wieder eure frage
zur deutschen sprache und zur deutschen
kultur und los geht's mit frage 1 ja
jemand mit dem schwierigen namen
xiaodong zu
vielleicht schreibt wie man das richtig
ausspricht schreibt carrey guten tag ich
habe eine frage über allein und alleine
in welcher situation sagt man allein und
wann alleine
könntest du mir das ein bisschen
erklären vielen dank der unterschied
zwischen allein und allein ist es gibt
keinen allein und alleine ist genau das
gleiche wort allein ist die korrekte
version und alleine ist die
umgangssprachliche version
und es gibt verschiedene sätze die
eigentlich genau das gleiche bedeuten
beispiel ich geh allein ins kino
ich gehe alleine ins kino kann man
beides genauso sagen ich habe keine
freunde ich bin so allein
ich habe keine freunde ich bin so
alleine beides genau die gleiche
bedeutung nur alleine ist ein bisschen
umgangssprachlicher als allein
eine interessante frage kommt von david
pearson david sagt ich habe eine frage
in welcher situation kann man den
artikel mit dem namen benutzen zum
beispiel in unserem video peter beim
friseur wurden diese sätze benutzt
wir sind heute in münster mit dem martin
das ist doch der peter ja sehr spannende
frage über die ich mich selber erst mal
informieren musste tatsächlich gibt es
nämlich da auch in deutschland regionale
variationen in nur deutschland werden
die artikel von den namen fast gar nicht
benutzt während in süddeutschland es
sehr üblich ist dass man einen artikel
vor einen
macht ja ihr fragt euch jetzt natürlich
wie sie german wird doch meistens in
norddeutschland produziert und die leute
die easy german machen oder bei easy
german vor der kamera stehen sind doch
alles nur deutsche warum benutzt ihr
dann artikel tatsächlich ist es so dass
das bei uns einfach lustig ging
normalerweise sprechen wir nämlich nicht
so ich sag zum beispiel carina kommt
nach hause
oder da vorne steht peter wenn ich
jedoch sage da vorne steht auch der
peter dann betone ich das in dem moment
und es klingt einfach ein bisschen
witziger das ist also der einzige grund
warum wir manchmal artikel vor dem namen
benutzen und manchmal nicht
marys oder mrs sagt hallo kari
weihnachten kommt bald was wäre ein
gutes weihnachtsgeschenk für deutsche
die antwort ist doch ganz einfach
schnaps also ohne scheiß
weihnachtsgeschenke oder überhaupt
allgemein geschenke sind doch echt eine
der kompliziertesten sachen die ist
überhaupt gibt denn geschenke kulturen
sind so unterschiedlich sogar in einem
land oder in einer familie kann das so
unterschiedlich seien ja manche leute
die finden geschenke total wichtig und
die schreiben sich sogar auf wer ihm was
geschenkt hat und die messen auch eine
freundschaft daran wäre was schenkt und
und ja die die erwarten dann auch dass
du dir total viel gedanken machst und
dass du die geschenke dass du dich da
schon irgendwie monate vorher darum
kümmert dann gibt es andere leute
wiederum die hassen geschenke und wenn
du den etwas schenkt was sie gar nicht
brauchen dann sind die wiederum
angepisst und ärgern sich dass sie jetzt
etwas haben womit sie gar nichts
anfangen können wenn man das ganze jetzt
auch noch international sieht wird ist
noch komplizierter denn in deutschland
ist es schon so unterschiedlich und dann
gibt es andere länder wo es noch ganz
andere geschenk kulturen wenn man zum
beispiel wenn wir in ein arabisches land
fahren
dann werden wir immer total beschenkt
und dass es halt ist dass das ist die
kultur zum beispiel in ägypten
dann komme ich hin als gast ja
normalerweise muss ja ich eigentlich was
mitbringen und fühle mich dann schlecht
und dann kriege ich auch noch geschenke
von meinen freunden
ich zu gast bin das ist manchmal schon
verrückt für uns und es ist interessant
diesen austausch zu sehen und auch mit
diesem austausch zu leben man kann ja
auch immer viel falsch machen
ja wenn du jetzt also wissen willst was
ein gutes weihnachtsgeschenk für
deutsche ist dann kann ich nur sagen
weiß ich nicht keine ahnung es gibt ja
nicht den deutschen und leute sind so
unterschiedlich jeder hat irgendwie
einen anderen geschmack wenn er etwas
schenken willst und die leute noch nicht
so gut kennt und auf nummer sicher gehen
willst dann hol dir doch einfach was was
man essen oder trinken kann dann kann
man fast nie was falsch mitmachen statt
zum beispiel ist wirklich eine gute idee
zu achten
ja der leyen mccue hatte da noch eine
frage zu diesem thema mit den ampeln ich
wir hatten ja darüber gesprochen dass
manche leute nicht bei rot über die
ampel gehen und er ist jetzt verwirrt
und fragt gibt es jetzt keine regel dass
man für grünes licht warten muss oder
hängt das von dem bundesland ab ja
natürlich gibt es eine regel
deshalb reden wir darüber das ganze
nennt sich verkehrsregel und die
verkehrsregeln sagen in ganz deutschland
sind die gleich in ganz deutschland sagt
die verkehrsregel bei rot muss man
stehen da einem fußgänger fahrrad auto
alles muss bei rot stehen beim in
unserem beispiel ging es ja darum ob man
als fußgänger nachts wenn keiner auf der
straße ist da nicht selber einfach mal
über die straße gehen kann und da sind
die kulturen verschieden in ganz vielen
ländern in der welt die man einfach
rüber beachtet die ampeln nicht so ganz
genau und deutschland eben sehr genau
die bleiben immer stehen ja
philippe erne unser freund philipp aus
brasilien fragt klar ich würde gerne
wissen über die religionen in
deutschland wie religiös oder nicht
religiös sind die deutschen ja philippe
das ist eine sehr spannende frage
und hier kann man zwei sachen machen ja
einmal auf die statistiken und ein mal
gucken wie es wirklich aussieht
statistisch gesehen sind 33 prozent der
deutschen konfessionslos das heißt sie
gehören keiner religion an
29 prozent der deutschen sind katholisch
28 prozent sind evangelisch und 4
prozent ungefähr sind muslimischen
glaubens das heißt statistisch gesehen
sind über 60 prozent der deutschen einer
religionsgemeinschaft zugehörig
das heißt sie haben offiziell eine
religion aber man muss sagen es ist
trotzdem nicht so dass 60 prozent der
deutschen wirklich religiös sind
natürlich muss man jetzt erst mal gucken
was ist überhaupt religiös denn es gibt
ja verschiedene formen von religiosität
manche leute gehen ganz oft in die
kirche manche leute gehören aber der
kirche auch nur an und gehen dort nie
hin
und so muss man auch in deutschland
gucken 60 prozent sind in der kirche
aber es gibt auch unter diesen 60
prozent leute die ihren glauben nicht
praktizieren und ich würde sagen dass
das auch ein bisschen typisch für
deutschland ist dass es traditionell
gehört man häufig einer konfession einer
religionsgemeinschaft an
aber die religion spielt gerade in der
jüngeren generation gar nicht mehr die
ganz große rolle die sie früher gespielt
hat das zeigt zum beispiel eine studie
aus dem jahr 2010 in der nur 26 prozent
aller jugendlichen in deutschland gesagt
haben dass sie an gott glauben ja das
ist auch so ein bisschen meine
einschätzung wenn ich so mich so um
gucke in meinem bekanntenkreis
freundeskreis auch im familienkreis
dann kenne ich sehr viele leute die eine
religion angehören
meistens katholisch oder evangelisch die
aber gar nicht mehr so religiös sind das
heißt religion spielt gar nicht so eine
große rolle in ihrem leben
spannend wird es dann wenn man das ganze
internationalen sie denn in vielen
ländern ist spielt religion nach wie vor
eine sehr große rolle gerade auch in
unserem zuschauer ländern
und das ist dann sehr spannend zu sehen
ich habe da meine karte gefunden die die
religiosität im internationalen
vergleich zeigt und das ist doch schon
sehr auffällig denn da sieht man das
wirklich vor allem in mitteleuropa und
in nordeuropa deutschland gehört auch so
ein bisschen dazu gerade da ist die
religiosität weniger und in vielen
anderen ländern der welt sind die
menschen eigentlich viel religiöser also
das ist etwas was sie auch wissen müsst
das ist ein bisschen typisch für
deutschland dass wir nicht so religiös
sind ja die zuschauer in der
zwischenzeit habe ich erst mal eine
halbe stunde mit meinem mann über
religion diskutiert das ist immer ein
ganz spannendes thema was wir noch mal
am ende dazu sagen wollten ist es gibt
auch in deutschland es gibt sozusagen
ein unterschied zwischen religiöser
lehre und glauben und auch der
religionsgemeinschaft mit ihren werten
denn es kann sein dass viele leute gar
nicht mehr sehr gläubig sind und nicht
oft in die kirche gehen ihren glauben
nicht praktizieren trotzdem spielen die
religionsgemeinschaften und ihre werte
und ihre institutionen eine riesige
rolle in der deutschen gesellschaft nach
wie vor ganz vieler ganz viele
institutionen wie schulen krankenhäuser
soziale institutionen sind von den
kirchen unterhalten werden von den
kirchen unterhalten
und ja die spiele nach wie vor eine
riesenrolle und ich würde schon sagen
dass die meisten leute daher sich auch
nicht ganz abwenden von der religion und
sich nicht ganz abwenden von ihrer
konfession sich fühlen sich irgendwie
dieser gemeinschaft zugehörig
auch wenn sie vielleicht auf der anderen
seite nicht unbedingt jeden sonntag in
die kirche gehen
letzte frage kommt von oliver kahn
warum sind deutsche serien und filme
so schlecht zum beispiel berlin tag &
nacht lola rennt tatort und so weiter so
hat sie das gerade wirklich gesagt hat
sie gesagt unsere filme sind schlecht
hat sie das gesagt na ja also ganz im
ernst viele deutschen finden ihre eigene
filme und ihre eigenen serien auch
schlecht
ich erinnere mich noch an seine zeit da
sind wir immer ins kino gegangen früher
in die sneak preview das war einmal die
woche wusste ja nicht welcher film kommt
und alle leute haben immer nur gehofft
bitte bitte hoffentlich kommt kein
deutscher film
weil das tatsächlich ein zeitlang so war
das echt 90 prozent aller deutschen
filme die in den kinos waren die waren
echt richtig schlecht
mittlerweile ist das aber nicht mehr
ganz so und es gibt mittlerweile echt
ein paar sehr sehr gute produktion
berlin tag & nacht gehört definitiv
nicht dazu
beim tatort wiederum ist das so eine
spannende sache vielen leuten die aus
dem ausland kommen den konnte dieser
tatort kult in deutschland völlig banane
und völlig freaky vor was ich mir
vorstellen können trotzdem lieben die
deutschen ihren tatort und der tatort
hat auch immer noch eine sehr hohe
priorität so in der deutschen
gesellschaft wenn ihr nicht wisst was
tatort ist das ist quasi ein
ein krimi ein eine ein kurzfilm der
läuft jeden sonntagabend auf deutsch in
ein ard in der ard und das gucken sich
die leute manchmal sogar in der kneipe
gemeinsam an weil das so populär ist
es gibt natürlich auch viele andere gute
deutsche filme und auch ein paar serien
wir werden euch jetzt in den nächsten
tagen auch auf unserer facebook seite
immer mal wieder ein paar deutsche
musiker und auch deutschsprachige filme
und serien vorstellen guckt einfach mal
rein
jan liebe zuschauer das war es auch
schon wieder für heute bei kari
antwortet am ende noch ein kleines
shoutout an steven levitt steven du bist
einer von unseren patriot
ermöglicht uns unsere arbeit und
unterstützt unsere arbeit du bist einer
der gründe warum wir in der lage sind
jede woche mittlerweile jeden tag ein
video zu produzieren
danke steve wir hoffen dass ihr uns auch
bei patrick scheint dass ihr uns
unterstützen das hilft uns wirklich
unglaublich ja und zum abschluss möchte
ich euch noch mal erinnern
schickt uns unsere kommentare letzte
woche haben wir nach kommentaren gerufen
und ein bisschen technomusik darunter
gemacht offenbar hat das geholfen werden
wir diese woche auch noch mal machen
denn wir brauchen mehr kommentare mehr
fragen mehr komische fragen mehr witzige
fragen mehr politische fragen alles wir
brauchen mehr von allem jazz und bis zur
nächsten woche
kommentare kommentare kommentare hier
unten ist der kommentare postet mehr
kommentare